I'm left okay and sometimes radically
and sometimes I even shocked myself with
the degree of a radical pneus in my own
then oh that's that I'm allowing to come
out in my old age on the other hand
there's some of my you know I got the
reputation of being a conservative
because I was one of these personal
responsibility guys you know before Bill
Cosby made it popular talking about how
black people need to pull up our socks
how need to take better care of our
children and you know get our acts
together and and how that was an
internal difficulty that we needed to
actually address within ourselves and I
even flirted a little bit with you know
sort of black nationalism I mean I had
more than a kind word to say about the
minister louis farrakhan I once wrote a
piece about the Million Man March 1995
Million Man March washington DC Louis
Farrakhan which is remembered I think
nowadays mostly because Farrakhan gave a
very odd and rambling and in places
incoherent and in other places kind of
weird speech it went on for 90 minutes
or something like that at this million
man march but the thing that I remember
was 1 million more or less
african-american men assembled in one
place emphasizing communal uplift
responsibility and you know a positive
agenda and I I was very much taken by
that and I guess that's still lingers in
me to some degree i also have this anti
political correctness thing that's a
part of my persona I mean I just haven't
drunk anybody's kool-aid you know what I
mean I mean I just can't go with them
with the flow i mean when chris matthews
thinks obama is great that's when I
start saying okay let me take another
look at this Obama you know what I mean
because this is you know so I just can't
and therefore I may be hard to
pigeonhole because I'm going to be on
you know the contrary inside or whatever
the thing might be I think the war on
terror is horrible I hated what the Bush
administration was doing on the other
hand I didn't think that we should
criminalize those policy differences by
going after these people after the fact
and I thought that all that bandwagon
stuff about how Eric Holder honor you
know let's prosecute them and let's
indict Bush and Cheney and a hot thought
it was crazy and irresponsible I'm you
know I'm likely to say something like
that
the one thing that I want to say is that
the progressive forces in our country
including those in the press I don't
think do the cause any good by not
reporting with brutal critical candor
and scrutiny on this administration
every bit as much as they would do on
any other administration now I hope that
in the fullness of time we're only nine
months into this eight months into this
I will be proven wrong about this but I
have detected from time to time a
reticence and a kind of as if the
campaign was still going on and we all
kind of know that people who are
covering campaigns and the press develop
allegiances and that co is the way in
which they do they're reporting I don't
think that's disputable I think there's
plenty of evidence to that effect on all
sides but the campaign has long since
over and we really need a hard-hitting
critical critical press I mean I see
elements of it but I don't see it to its
full extent I'm talking about for
example on these questions of war and
peace I don't take it as a given at all
that we need to be doubling down in
Afghanistan I don't take that as a given
at all that's the direction in which the
president is going I want hard hitting
critical assessment of that from the
liberal and progressive media not merely
he's our guy we got to protect him kind
of reaction that is somehow what I feel
like I'm getting from my little small
part in my little corner of the the
public policy world and you know I write
about race and affirmative action and
racial discrimination and you know
domestic policy and prisons and all this
kind of thing I'm sure determined to do
that I'm determined as I was trying to
do in reaction to this andrew lewis
gates affair to call the president out
when I think he's making mistakes and
when I think he's got it when he's got
it wrong and to do that as a part of my
you know responsibility as a you know
public intellectual and so forth and so
on so for what that may be worth I'll
say that
that's right my pastor this little
church that I used to go to when I was a
better Christian than I am now who and
his wife had devoted their physicians
harvard-trained physician his devoted
his entire life to building a church in
a community in boston and has helped
thousands and thousands of people and
it's as pious and is serious and as
humane a human being as you come you
might imagine Reverend Ray Hammond I'm
glad to be able to put him at the top of
my list no I'm not running for anything
in Boston I don't need his endorsement
but he certainly he's certainly a good
man another guy I think of who I admired
tremendously is Ernesto Cortez who's a
well-known community organizer the
industrial areas foundation he works out
of Austin Texas but he's organizing
throughout the southwest and I'm known
in between 25 years and I tell you that
these community organizers of some of
these places you know in New Orleans and
in houston and san antonio and la
various cities around the southwest I've
had a chance to interact with them down
in the Rio Grande Valley you know with
the Mexican immigrant population and
stuff like that organizing I've been to
you know holiday ends at the airport and
500 people wearing the tame same t-shirt
have been jumping up and down inside an
auditory I'm talking about they were
going to get a community college
education so they could run one of these
MRI machines at the hospital or
something like that they were talking
about we want twenty-five dollars an
hour jobs not minimum-wage jobs and
we're prepared to you know and I just
see not to go on too long about it but
here's a guy who is spending his life
he's a thoughtful he's an intellectual
this is ernesto court tells the
organizer he's an intellectual but he's
also a practical politician and when i
say that i don't mean that he's running
for office but I mean he's dealing with
the kind of small p politics getting
people together getting them talking to
each other getting them to feel that
they have the capacity to change their
lives getting them organized have
tremendous respect to them
you